it was four decades long and suddenly it
was over Robert Mugabe stood down the
army had made it non-negotiable his
reign was over from the streets they
celebrated pure amazement and pure shock
[Applause]
in Robert Mugabe's world inflammatory
rhetoric translated into harsh rule he's
gone but the country he created will
take years to recover
determined to rise from his humble
beginnings in a one parent family he
trained as a teacher engaged seven
university degrees ambitious intelligent
and impatient political activism saw him
jailed and exiled he returned to fight
against the illegal regime of Ian Smith
as a guerrilla commander and leader of
his party zanu-pf after years of
fighting and months of negotiations 1979
brought an end to white rule and the
birth of democracy in a new Zimbabwe
when independence day he
enthusiastically accepted the
congratulations of Prince Charles but
the Democrat was soon to turn despotic
secure with victory at the polls Robert
Mugabe opened chapter 1 in the tyrants
textbook and set about removing
potential political rivals from power
mcgaubey
planned a one-party state his opponent
brutally massacred in their thousands in
Matabeleland all opposition's snuffed
out as he secured control but JimBob Way
prospered promising to be post-colonial
Africa's economic and social success
story enriching whites and blacks alike
[Music]
Garvey himself was fated by the West but
that change
autocratic and corrupt his style of
government proved disastrous for the
economy once known as Africa's
breadbasket Zimbabwe became an economic
basket case as food riots erupted he
found a way to channel simmering unrest
unleashing supporters on the country's
white farmers the backbone of its
agricultural economy the government
seizure of estates began white flight
and financial meltdown as the economy
disintegrated
he warned Europeans in general and the
British government in particular against
interfering we have one now independence
and we are prepared to shed our blood in
sustenance and maintenance and
protection of that independence we have
not asked for any inch of Europe and
square inch of that territory so Blair
keep your England and let me keep my
Zimbabwe in a rare interview he told Sky
News that foreign powers should keep
their noses out of Zimbabwe affairs
when the situation is amorphous and the
people do not have that sense of
nationalism then of course you can be
undermined very easily and undermined by
external forces that's why what
countries like Britain want us to be so
they can you know be using their
neo-colonialist methods you see to try
and affect our countries by way of
sabotage by way of trying to rule us in
indirectly
though he claimed a further presidential
mandate in 2002 persistent questions
over the polls conduct began to lose in
barway its dwindling call of foreign
friends the Movement for Democratic
Change under the leadership of Morgan
Chandler I accused him of rigging the
vote despite sanctions and international
condemnation President Mugabe remained
unrepentant and unrestrained Django
himself was savagely beaten by police
during an anti-government protest
hilarious suspected of supporting the
opposition were bulldozed in the name of
slum clearance much of the foreign media
was bad whether he actually believed it
or not to the end he argued he was right
and his country's problems were caused
by outsiders casting his last vote as
president he conceded if you lose an
election and are rejected by the people
it's time to leave politics
while mcgarvey and his inner circle
amassed fortunes with apparent impunity
his marriage to grace an ambitious and
greedy first lady began to turn the
public and more importantly the military
against him
their extravagant shopping trips and her
son's posting huge drink spills on
social media and pouring champagne over
$60,000 watches appalled many but graces
efforts to become a husband successor
signaled the end for President Kagame
the military took over the streets and
the gobby's former right-hand man
Emerson Managua returned to a rapturous
inauguration as the new president for
[Applause]
Mugabe the closing bell had finally
chimed as he long feared it might I know
what it is you know to work with people
to hear them talk to allow them to you
know play a part in in your life and
this this is I think what is carrying me
to this day and although I sit here as
president I know that the that post I
owe to the people in truth he leaves a
battered country still hoping that
democracy may flourish once more a
return to a democracy whose values he
trampled whose rewards he squandered and
whose people he ported
[Music]
it will be a challenge but Robert
Gabriel Mugabe won't be there still
Ramsay Sky News